Speaker 1: Hey, here's some fascinating
news. Mypillow CEO and founder Mike Lindell,
known to us, of course, simply as pillow.
Speaker 4: We're doing a class
action lawsuit against all machines.
Speaker 1: He has been ordered to pay $5 million
for his prove mike wrong election fraud
challenge. Now, Pillow has been on the show before
and he has this reward. If you can prove to me the
election wasn't stolen, I'll give you a 5 million
bucks. Well, a judge is saying he's going to have
to pay a Washington Post report. This is just the
best. Mypillow founder and prominent election
denier Mike Lindell made a bold offer ahead of
his cyber symposium, or as he calls it, a cyber ZM
he held in August 2021 in South Dakota. He claimed
he had data showing Chinese interference and said
he would pay $5 million to anyone who could prove
the material was not from the previous year's
U.S. election. He called it Prove Mike wrong.
On Wednesday, a private arbitration panel ruled
someone did, the panel said Robert Zeidman,
a computer forensics expert. Oh, sounds like a
cyber guy. And 63 year old Trump voter from Nevada
was entitled to the $5 million. Zeidman
had examined Lindell's data and concluded
not only did it not prove voter fraud, it has no
connection to the 2020 election. He was the only
expert who submitted a claim. He turned to the
arbitrators after Lindell Management refused to
pay him in a 23 page decision, the arbitrator
said Zeidman proved the material from Pillow
unequivocally did not reflect November 2020
election data. They have directed Lindell's
firm to pay Zeidman within 30 days. Zeidman
says he's really happy. They clearly saw this,
as I did, that the data we were given at the
symposium was not at all what Pillow said it
was. The truth is finally here, Zeidman attorney,
said the panel's decision is a warning to others
who have made wild allegations about election
fraud. I will say this is not good for Pillow,
who is already taking loans to keep his company
afloat, Lindell said in a text to the Post. Quote,
They made a terribly wrong decision. This will be
going to court. In the meantime, I have to add,
my pillow is now under lawsuit. Pillow is under
lawsuit in a major situation involving Dominion
voting systems. This is a whole other problem for
pillow attacks on dominion voting persist despite
high profile lawsuits. This is an argument, an
article from the New York Times Dominion Why don't
you show us what's inside your machines? Mike
Lindell, the Mike Pillow executive, an election
denier, shouted during a live stream last month.
He added that the company, which has filed a $1.3
billion defamation suit against him, was engaged
in the biggest cover up for the biggest crime in
United States history, probably in world history.
Folks, Pillow is destroying himself. He told me
when I last interviewed him that he had spent
about $35 million on all of this nonsense. I'm
sure it is way more than that at this point in
time. You've got to add the 5 million bucks that
he owes the debunker. And here he is explaining
to Stephen Bannon that everybody got it wrong.
Everybody got it wrong as well.
Speaker 4: It is the reality is
fake is the biggest scandal. Here I
am on a family trip with my grandkids
and I chat from all over the country, adding
news reporters call me all day. Isn't it kind
of strange? Just comes out the day after
Fox settles with Dominion? This guy is
not a cyber guy. I don't even know how he
got in there with his credentials. He has
he's an IT guy, a computer guy, but he's not.
Speaker 1: He's an I.T. guy and a computer guy,
but not a cyber guy. Can someone
tell me what on earth Mike Pillow
thinks? A cyber guy is a cyber guy.
Speaker 4: Now you say, Well, why do
these guys rule against this? Well, three of the
three arbitrators are left. Democrats. We only
had a you only get a little pool to choose from.
Speaker 1: Oh, my goodness. This guy is out of
his mind. He really is. And I have to tell you,
it is sad to a degree. I think pillow I think
pillow's life is in shambles. And he's even said
there's not only been an incredible financial cost
to all of this, there's been a family cost as
well. He's traveling all the time. He doesn't
see his family up and down on his plane looking at
voting machines and stained ballots and all these
different things. This guy has destroyed himself
of his own doing. And it is sad to a degree,
but he has been so corrosive and destructive
to the pillars of American democracy that I
have to say, my my empathy only goes so far.
He really does deserve what he's getting,
even if he did a year of this stuff. He could have
stopped a year and a half ago and he wouldn't be
in nearly this much trouble. So it's going to cost
him and it seems like it's going to cost him big.
And if you look at the clip we just played, you
can find it on our Instagram or on our YouTube
channel or Facebook or wherever. Tiktoks You
really see that this guy is beaten down and it
doesn't make me happy. But at some point we have
to say, Listen, when you go and go and go and go
for years and all of the facts are there and you
choose to ignore them or to claim that they're
wrong or whatever the case may be, at a certain
point, there are going to be consequences for
your actions. And for pillow, it looks like
it's racking up about a $50 million bill.